on Saturday Archie's grandmother Doria
Raglan is expected to attend his
christening at Windsor Castle along with
about 20 to 25 guests and we're really
hoping that you know the Clooney's the
Beckham Serena Williams and Oprah could
be tapped as godparents I personally
think it would be unlikely I think they
are more likely to go with close friends
people who Harry has grown up with this
fall Archie will be on board as his mom
and dad make an official trip to Africa
but the baby's itinerary will be limited
my understanding is that Megan and
Archie will stay based largely in South
Africa probably in Johannesburg and from
Johannesburg Harry will travel to
Botswana to Malawi and to Angola where
he will carry out engagement and it
seems people are already speculating on
when there could be a baby Sussex number
- they absolutely want siblings for
Archie possibly we will have a second
pregnancy announcement for Megan and
Harry at some point next year so I think
at the moment they're focusing on Archie
but I know it's their plan to have more
than one child
you